Speaker 1: So at the start of today's
show, we went over the passage in the
House of Representatives of a much smaller
$1.2 trillion infrastructure bill, and this
may be good for Joe Biden. Joe Biden needs
something good. Joe Biden needs to get something
done. The negotiation on this bill has dragged on
too long, in particular for how relatively little
you actually got in the bill. And increasingly,
there is this urgency for an accomplishment for
Joe Biden. Because if we just look at the numbers,
this is just an empirical reality of Joe Biden's
approval rating has hit another presidency low,
the lowest point of Joe Biden's entire presidency
now. I tend not to look at any one poll. I look at
an average of polls fivethirtyeight.com tracks an
average of Biden approval polls. And if you're
watching today, rather than just listening, you
will see on your screen right now that there has
been a steady decline for Joe Biden's approval.
This started around late July, and I mentioned
it to you when it started. And it has continued
to decline, and this has pulled Joe Biden
down from around 53 percent approval below 50
into the high 40s, mid 40s and now down to the
low 40s forty two point six percent approval.
That's the lowest of Joe Biden's presidency. Now,
anecdotally, if you want to pick one poll, there
are some polls that have Joe Biden in the 30s,
and you could say disaster, even bigger disaster.
There are some polls that still have Joe Biden
near 50. On average, he is now in the low 40s.
Now there is not one explanation for this, and
you need to understand a little bit of history in
general to even start to interpret these results.
And there's this kind of systemic historical
reality of presidential approval, which is that it
typically starts sort of high. And then typically,
as the president does things that different
people don't like, people change from saying,
I approve, too. I don't approve, and it's really
difficult to get someone who stops approving
back into the I approve category or column, which
is why presidential approval tends to decline over
time, and that's what we see over the majority of
presidencies. Now, for Joe Biden, the trajectory
has basically been approval started declining when
the delta wave of COVID started to look really,
really bad. That's middle to late July, and we
saw the approval start to decline, as I said
at the time. Ultimately, the buck stops with Joe
Biden. The truth is, the delta wave was more out
of control in the United States than it had to
be because of red state governors, anti-maskers
and anti-vaxxers, really. They were to blame for
the exacerbation of the Delta wave, not Joe Biden,
but Joe Biden, the president, and the buck stops
with him. And it's logical that if things are
looking out of control, his approval would decline
now before Biden could recover from that initial
decline. He was then hit with another problem,
which was the withdrawal from Afghanistan. The
withdrawal was correct. The right move, the right.
I supported it completely. It was time to go.
It would have been just as chaotic if Donald
Trump had done it, if not more. But it was
Biden who did it, and the buck stops with him and
the media narrative, particularly from the right,
but also from some centrists. Corporate
media of chaos really hurt Joe Biden further.
As people started to forget about Afghanistan,
remember how long has it been since anyone
mentioned it? It started to become What is Joe
Biden doing? Chaos at the border was a right wing
narrative. When is Biden going to have a big
accomplishment? Became a broader and accurate
narrative. That's a real question. When is Joe
Biden going to have his next major accomplishment?
He needed something a big piece of legislation,
the negotiation around the infrastructure bill
and the build back better bill. It dragged
on and on. The attention became the relative
power that Joe Manchin and Kirsten Cinema had,
rather than Joe Biden. It was taking oxygen,
and the approval continues to decline. We now
have some shortages and supply chain issues,
which we had under Trump. Gas prices and
inflation have climbed as the pandemic
recovery continues and Joe Biden is president
so fairly or unfairly, he gets blamed that's
the game. So now he finds himself at the bottom.
I mean, so far the bottom, it could continue down.
He is currently at the bottom of his presidency's
approval. Now you combine this with last week's
losses and barely wins for Democrats. 2022
can't be said to be looking good right now
for those who say it's not looking that bad,
OK? There's no indicator that 2022 looks good.
First, the first midterm for a party that
wins the White House is typically not good.
In addition, Biden is at his approval low of his
presidency. Plus, Democrats had some bad signals
during last week's elections. Now that being said,
Joe Biden is still doing better today than Donald
Trump was. At 292 days into his presidency, Biden
is doing worse than most presidents were right
now. Obama was more popular at this point in
his presidency. George W. Bush, thanks to 911,
was way more popular. Clinton was more popular
than Biden at this point in his presidency. George
H.W. Bush was more popular. Reagan was more
popular. But at this point in Trump's presidency,
Trump's approval had already collapsed to 37
percent and Biden's between 42 and 43. So at
least that's something to look at. Trump was still
worse. That all being said, we may simply be in a
sort of new era of politics in which presidential
approval is mostly low because it's expected
that if the person in the White House is from the
other party, you say you don't approve regardless
of what the president has actually done. It's
a sad reality we may be facing. Biden does need
more wins that I can assure you, and we'll see
where the approval is a couple of weeks from now